ten minutes ago
we finished watching netflix's project
power
a film that had a pretty bitching
trailer
does it live up to the hype is it a
powerful movie
i don't know if i'd use that word to
describe it in case you guys haven't
seen the trailer here's the high
concept pitch for y'all what if there
was a pill
that could give you powers for five
minutes
and who knows what that power's gonna be
it could be a good one
you could just explode one thing's for
sure it'll land in the hands of
criminals that's right and they'll ruin
the streets of new orleans
which is the movie all right so in this
movie you have three main characters
essentially
jamie foxx um who plays a character
named art and as showed in the trailer
he is
looking for his daughter and that
involves somehow
going through the hierarchy of the
criminal underbelly of all the people
who are supplying
the drug is there a name for the drug in
the movie i think they call it power i
think it's called
project power what's stupid am i yeah
what's your name
what's that called what does it do you
got your other character here who is a
cop in new orleans who doesn't like
what's going on yeah you're not going to
see your evil drug on my city
after all the terrible things that
already happened in new orleans joseph
gordon-levitt he plays a character named
frank
he's taking the law to his own hands by
occasionally taking the pill himself in
order to match up against the criminals
and then you got this character named
robin played by dominique
fishbach that's how you say it all three
do great jobs
all three are pretty freaking excellent
in this film i want to just get this out
of the way
right now dominique fishback blew me
away yeah she is so
natural on screen it's amazing there was
at least three times where i just looked
john and go man this woman is amazing
why haven't i she her before yeah she
she really is the heart like there's
a lot of great connective hearts yeah
but yeah she's the heart and soul of the
movie and she's a big part of what
connects the storyline between joseph
gordon-levitt
and uh jamie foxx that's more than just
this
you know taking down the bad guy pursuit
that she helps bring out the real
character
in there so yeah dominique fishback
she's a performer i want to see
way more of as for the movie itself i
didn't know really what
to expect other than the awesome trailer
that we got if you get this really
awesome trailer and all i wanted was a
really
badass summer movie on netflix then i go
on like
rotten tomatoes and i'm like reading the
capsules for it and at the time i don't
know what it's at right now but at the
time was like 73 percent
okay everyone was kind of just saying
like essentially how i felt about the
old guard
[Laughter]
was that netflix is doing a great job at
like okay action movies you know i've
seen some like thumbnails of some
youtube reviewers out there so
my my expectations actually went down
just from that actually
i watched this film and i really liked
it i thought it was
really cool i it gave me 100 whatever we
said in that reaction
it gave me all of that and a little bit
more if i'm being honest it commits
enough to its idea to be just as fun as
you want it to be the effects are good
enough that it's just as bombastic and
action-packed as you want it to be but
again it's that secret
edge of the acting performances and the
writing of the characters that does
give the movie some heft and some weight
and some actual emotional resonance
my main concern was that it would be a
little boring in between the action
scenes
like in the old guard i don't want to
slog that
movie that's just the recent netflix
action movie but yeah having seen i feel
like there
are things i liked about both movies
that are very similar but what that
movie lacked for me this movie
really made up for which was in the
writing and the character stuff and the
things that held
together between action set pieces
exactly and the directing of this i
thought was great the way this film is
shot there are some truly
memorable action sequences in here and
the trailer doesn't give away
all of the action sequences they don't
give away
all of the powers that you'll see in the
movie so we're not going to give it away
but there was actually a lot of cool
surprises and what i loved with the
you know the ignition of the powers
after people take the capsules and even
some post
after the powers are wearing off it's
like some of the body horror elements
that they throw in here yeah
there's a good amount of that these
really interesting cellular images and
just pictures of like plasmic
you know fluids spreading apart and it
really does translate the physical
rush of the experience to you and from
our understanding this movie's not
based on a graphic novel or something
even though it deals with like super
powers
even though it borrows a lot of like
superhero tropes especially like the
reasoning for the pills
if anything the the lackluster part of
it
in the writing would be just some of the
ideas but i thought the execution
was good like rodrigo santoro is the
main bad guy
at first especially like early on in the
movie it's like
guys the most like cliche actually is
like first couple scenes there he is
yeah as cliche as it gets but then he
has some scenes later on in the movie
room like rodrigo centaur was killing
this role man he's doing great
well that's the thing is there are
setups and there are themes and things
that are familiar but the thing is the
movie again just commits to all of them
and goes okay well what would logically
happen next to this person once the plan
doesn't go according to plan
yeah and again that's what makes even
characters like that surprise you with
being a little more fun to watch and a
little more fun to invest in than you
would have thought at the beginning of
the movie
because this movie is like a crime
thriller meets a superhero movie while
it's kind of dark tonally it has that
energy that you'll see in the trailer
it's a very vibrant film at the same
time yeah like it's not based on a
graphic novel but the way the movie is
composed
so much of its shots were just stellar
there was some great shots in here the
action scenes and the choreography were
awesome it sounds like we're being paid
to talk about this movie
how much phrase we're giving it i just
kind of want to defend the movie now
even though i didn't read a lot of
hate on the film uh it was more so that
i feel like this movie's kind of being
undersold now i personally thought it
was really
impressive in a lot of areas i wasn't
mind blown necessarily but i was very
impressed and there were
literally there are some action
sequences one involving
like uh i'll just say a tank i won't say
what kind of tank
but the way they deal with perspective
in a lot of shots
there's a lot of mounting shots as well
where they decide to place the camera on
certain performers
or on certain spots in the environment
on a technical scale i don't think
there's any denying that the
directing editing effects the pacing
it was weird because there was a point
when okay it was gonna be over in like
20 minutes i was like what the hell
they're still 40 minutes 40 minutes left
yeah yeah yeah and then it kept going
and i was still really enjoying the
movie well because what they have to do
i was sitting there yeah
being like damn what else are we gonna
oh no this does seem like what we would
have had to have done
especially to get everyone to the
conclusion we need them to be at because
it is
something of an ensemble admittedly
though in the last 20 to 30 minutes
i i did look at john and say about 10
minutes ago they decided they need to
get this movie under two hours because
there are certain chunks in the finale
where it just started seeming like they
were rushing it why are we suddenly
moving like moving through this so fast
now
yeah you know and there is some of that
i bet you know action movie budgeting of
time where it's like well we know we've
got to get to a certain point
we've seen a lot we don't want to
overwhelm people but i think for a lot
of it anyway they they avoided getting
long in the tooth and i do have to give
props to
henry juiced and ariel schumann because
they have grown in their visual style
like i first discovered them through
catfish and then paranormal activity
three
you know they came out of for me found
footage and the way that they have grown
their visual style to incorporate
effects really well and various lenses
like we talked about and stuff is really
impressively put together
you know they have well-rooted
characters in here and there's a lot of
funny scenes as well i mean are there
some scenes that fall a little flat
yeah but i don't i none of those really
stand out to me there's some like
the very opening scene made me go oh man
i don't know about the team
like the very very opening kind of
yeah there are things at the top where
you'll be like okay i see where you're
going and then they actually managed to
again surprise you yeah yeah because
structurally it kind of
uh is a little odd at first it kind of
sets it up in a way where
joseph gordon-levitt's the main
character and jamie foxx will be the
main supporting character
10 minutes later you realize oh no it's
actually the complete opposite way
around yeah yeah i really enjoyed jamie
foxx's performance and joseph
gordon-levitt i thought was really
charming there were
parts in the script for his character
though that i thought were a little bit
the phrase is deus ex machina right you
kind of just show up at like
the perfect time consistently or come in
the in the story at the perfect time to
mess things up
yeah and there are a couple of those
that are justified and there are a
couple of those that are just like you
must just have a really great sentence
yeah
timing you know i thought he was great
in the movie honestly i have
very little complaints other than a few
odd moments
yeah it's very sparse though yeah it
could be smoothed out here or there but
for the most part it really moves
confidently
yeah and i can't say that the way the
movie is executed is generic the way the
script is
it really could have been executed in a
generic way
but i think with its technical
achievements and the pacing and the
style all that uh involved help make
this feel unique and stand out from some
of the superhero movies that we have
today
yeah i would say that this is a good
example of a movie that doesn't
necessarily reinvent its wheel but it
does roll it with
so much style yeah i think it would be
kind of hard not to enjoy if you're big
into
action sci-fi superhero stuff man the
character stuff is enjoyable yeah now we
gotta talk about a couple things before
we wrap this review up machine gun
kelly's in this movie hey he is
he gets a cool set piece he gets more to
do than casey neistat
that's for sure casey neistat is in this
movie
here's my experience with casey neistat
here's how some of his performance
he shows up on screen and i go oh i
forgot
casey neistat's in this movie yep the
movie ends
and we're doing a review oh i forgot
yeah you know he's he gives some great
reaction shots
like were you friends with the director
or something like what favor were you
doing
it's very possible don't throw this
mother effer's name on the credits what
the hell man yeah do you see him in the
trailer and you're like okay maybe he's
gonna be part of like a gallery he's
gonna get funny
yeah yeah you know lowlifes who want to
buy the drug and he's going to have a
bit or whatever but yeah
i'm not ruining anything for you guys
nothing if you're coming to this movie
for casey neistat he has about as much
screen time as courtney b
vance which is not much the courtney b
vance has at least an important thing to
do
he has a scene that is important yeah
casey neistat is just wallpaper
yeah one of that i recommend watching
this all right
we're not we don't have theaters i mean
most places don't have theaters open if
you're looking for a really great
escapism fun
superhero time i really enjoyed it a lot
am i lying
huh that's a reference am i lying i'm
not lying
i mean this is a movie that i wish i
could have now seen in a theater so i
feel like that is a good review for any
netflix
at this point yeah yeah all right guys
well did you see project power
what did you think about it if you
enjoyed the movie hit the like button if
you liked our review
hit the like button subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell and last but not least
victoria huntley i haven't talked to you
in a while victoria i wanted to shout
you out today
by using adjectives that describe how
awesome you are
through the letters of your first name v
for vicarius
okay i for
insightful ooh take it away because c is
john
c for courteous t
for triumphant o for
omnipresent you can do the r
r for resplendent
oh wow you're trying to impress someone
for
imaginative
oh we did it we got words victoria
huntley thank you so much for being part
of our patreon page i hope you're being
safe right now
you